[Musique]
si on prend le problème de l'égalité
dans la procréation
on dira pourquoi de femmes y auraient
droit et pourquoi deux hommes n'y aurait
pas droit
je veux pas que dans quelques années on
se réveille hagard dans un monde trans
humaniste où l'on créerait des bébés sur
mesure en méconnaissant au fond la
nature même de l'humanité
or on n'a pas droit à un être humain on
a droit des objets ou mais sinon c'est
un problème de liberté
la famille c'est libre sexualité doit
être libre mais pour autant on n'a pas
droit à une personne humaine aujourd'hui
on peut faire admettre alors qu'on nous
parle de la taxe carbone que l'on va
faire venir de la vie entière qui est
excédentaire en france qui va traverser
qui va traverser les mers pour venir
chez nous alors qu'elle utilise des
produits phytosanitaires qui sont
interdits on ne peut pas avoir à la fois
le dumping social le jumping énergétique
le dumping agricole sa cet anti
écologique et je ne vois pas comment on
pourrait autoriser des importations
d'aliments qui sont aujourd'hui
interdites à la production franchement
alors qu'on a un vote sur le c'est un la
ratification du traité avec le canada
qui va augmenter les émissions de co2 de
détourner l'attention du public en
faisant bénir cette ratification par une
égérie dit des jeunes qui lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique je considère
en effet que notre responsabilité
ça n'est pas de se soumettre à des
gourous apocalyptique mais c'est au
contraire de prendre des décisions
éclairées par des connaissances
scientifiques
[Musique]